aquí en color rojo tenemos la gráfica de
la equis cuadrada menos 3 y en azul
tenemos la gráfica de igual a x 4a menos
4 x cuadrada más 1 el objetivo de este
vídeo es usar nuestro conocimiento de
cálculo para encontrar el área entre
estas dos gráficas que está sombreada de
color amarillo puedes ver que queremos
el área entre dos curvas por lo tanto
usar una integral definida será útil
ahora cuáles son nuestros límites de
integración bueno van a ser los valores
de x donde las gráficas se intersectan
el límite inferior es donde las gráficas
en tercer khanaqin y el límite superior
es donde las gráficas intersectan acá
parece que la primera intersección es el
punto menos uno menos dos y podemos
verificarlo cuando x es igual a menos
uno mi función de rojo vale menos uno
esto elevado al cuadrado menos tres lo
cual es menos 2
puedes verlo aquí en la gráfica y cuando
x es igual a menos 1 mi función de azul
vale menos
uno elevado a la cuarta menos cuatro por
menos uno elevado al cuadrado más uno lo
cual también es menos 2
también puedes verlo aquí en la gráfica
ahora bien puedes usar el mismo
argumento para probar que x igual a 1 es
otro punto de intersección observa uno
menos tres es menos dos y uno menos
cuatro por uno más uno es igual a menos
dos también por lo tanto ya tenemos los
dos valores de x en donde se intersectan
las funciones y nuestros límites de
integración serán desde x igual a menos
1 hasta x igual a 1 ahora podemos ver
que en el intervalo que nos interesa la
gráfica de azul es mayor que la gráfica
de rojo por lo tanto la gráfica de
azules será nuestro borde superior ya
esa función le arrestaremos la función
de rojo que es nuestro borde inferior
entonces pondré x cuarta menos 4x
cuadrada más 1 ya esto le restaría x
cuadrado menos
y bueno claro al final hay que
multiplicar todo por de equis recuerda
que en vídeos anteriores concluimos que
estos siempre funcionan tomar la
diferencia de la función que es el borde
superior del área menor la función que
nos da el borde inferior del área así
que simplemente tenemos que calcularla
esto nos quedarán como la integral
definida de menos uno a uno de y bueno
tengo x cuarta menos 4 x 4 adam - x
cuadrada me observan se distribuyó este
signo negativo sobre la expresión de
rojo me va a quedar menos x cuadrada y
tengo menos 4x cuadrada - x cuadrada eso
es menos 5x cuadrada ok y después tengo
1 y a esto le voy a quitar menos 3 por
lo que uno menos menos tres es lo mismo
que uno más tres que es 4
y todo esto por de x
debemos ser claro toda esta expresión de
arriba está multiplicada por de x por lo
tanto también voy a poner paréntesis es
importante y ahora puedo encontrar la
anti derivada de una manera sencilla que
es utilizar la inversa de la regla de la
potencia varias veces esta será bueno x
elevado a la quinta sobre 5 sólo estoy
aplicando la inversa de la regla de la
potencia aumentar en 1 el exponente y
dividir por esa misma cantidad menos 5x
elevado al cubo entre 3 + 4x esto
evaluado primero en 1 ya esto le
quitaremos la evaluación en menos 1 si
lo evalúa en 1 bueno vamos a ver que
obtengo un quinto menos 5 tercios más 4
ok ya esto le voy a quitar la evaluación
en menos 1 lo cual es menos 1 elevado a
la quinta potencia entre 5 bueno esto es
menos un quinto después tengo menos 5
tercios por este signo menos me va a
quedar más 5 tercios y por último menos
1 por 4
4 ahora voy a distribuir este signo
negativo de modo que todo lo que está
dentro del paréntesis cambiará de signo
este será positivo este será negativo y
este será positivo solo distribuir el
signo negativo y entonces me va a quedar
a un quinto más un quinto son dos
quintos y después tengo menos cinco
tercios menos cinco tercios bueno esos
menos diez tercios más ocho ok y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que este ocho más y
ahora voy a escribir tanto dos quintos
como menos diez tercios con un
denominador común y mi denominador común
es quince por lo tanto dos quintos es lo
mismo que 615 ambos y diez tercios es lo
mismo que en menos 50 quince abós y
bueno ahora tenemos ya un denominador
común por lo tanto voy a tomarme la
diferencia de 615 ambos menos 50 15
ambos lo cual va a ser menos 44 15 años
entonces me queda 8 menos 44 15 ambos
si por acá arriba veo que 44 15 a vos es
lo mismo que 2 enteros 2 por 1530 y nos
sobran 14 14 15 a vos ok entonces tengo
8 menos 2 enteros 14 15 a 28 menos 26 y
6 menos 14 15 a vos es 5 enteros un
quinceavo de lujo y todo esto unidades
cuadradas porque estamos hablando del
área así que ya lo tenemos
de esta manera encontramos esta área que
estábamos buscando nos veremos en el
próximo vídeo